[Music]
clapping we just met I just got back
from my cousin's wedding total waste of
time like they got married for love
which I don't get and I don't know if
that's right or wrong but like I want to
get married but everyone I know we get
some and they get married because they
want to find a soulmate or they want to
start a family or they're in love
doesn't compute to me I want to get
married but I'm just trying to put my
mom down as an emergency contact anybody
else still deliver that in their 30s
still putting her mom down on apartment
applications is frustrating bands fill
this stuff out who should be called in
case of emergency call my mommy call my
mommy she know all of my allergies and
everything covered my mom flew to the
wedding she didn't want to drive she
complains about gas prices which I don't
get if you're still complaining about
debt why are you still mad about Gaspar
you think it's gonna go back down to
whatever it was when you were 16 it's
not horse if it's that it to you just go
get a horse or something else because
all they do with gas prices they play
with the gas prices to distract you from
the stuff that they're actually making
money off of us on so last time you
bought a smaller soda at the movie
theater that's what they're making the
money you worried about the price of gas
a small soda is $15 it would be cheaper
to drink a gallon of gas
just sipping a gallon of Chevron you and
your date please okay baby it's 93
you're special that's the good that's
the good stuff I travel now you know I
go out relax when I'm on the road I like
museums man my favorite thing of the
museum the caveman exhibit caveman
hands-down most gangster ass dude to
walk the face of the earth
there's nobody tougher than the caveman
you know the caveman was a gangster just
how they find the body
every time they dig it became normally
when they find dead bodies from back in
a day they're either entombed and
covered in jewelry or at some end of the
world pose every caveman same ganks fast
poster who you know die like that
justice and he froze to death not long a
pace to freeze you think you would find
them covered up with other cavemen you
know as the caveman had to come at all
hey man it's getting cold
we should get your ass up off me bring
it [ __ ]
black gangster love all that stuff love
educational trips Marilyn the museum I
got kicked out the zoo but it first of
all I didn't know the zoo had a bouncer
but he's there he's working
this dude is efficient come to an
argument at the zoo
you never zoo does this where they had
the pandas that come over from China and
they make a big deal about it and the
commercial that's what gets you that's
why you go see the Pam it's a commercial
[Music]
so I go to this Panda Pavilion at the
zoo you know you're all gonna do it and
after like 10 15 minutes around behind
the bush under the log the pavilion and
the zookeepers walking by hey hey
where's duck sauce she snapped on me sir
the pandas are sleep okay so will you go
wake them up and tell them they have
company outside pay money to see their
ass sir we can't predict when the pandas
will or won't be in the exhibit we just
ask that you in the meantime be quiet
and enjoy their natural habitat I want
to draw a reef on in my hair
[Applause]
sweet and acceptable excuse for you to
screw me every day they just sleep I'm
just supposed to let that slide cuz they
sleep the zoo it's a performance you pay
money you go in there the animals come
out and they do that show you wouldn't
accept sleepers an excuse anywhere else
god forbid you ever see me in your town
you pay money to see me your sit in a
chair for two hours and nothing happened
management just comes out on stage we're
sorry the black dude is sleep but enjoy
his natural habitat
[Applause]